one of the reasons small YouTube
channels fail is they fail to start and
they fail to stick with it I think that
a lot of small channels want to get
disproportionate success results without
putting in the necessary amount of work
the definition of luck is when hard work
and preparation meet so what does that
mean it means I'm making opportunities
it means I'm uploading videos it means
that the more up videos I upload the
more chances I have to have a breakout
video
while starting a YouTube channel
technically means getting a Gmail
address and setting up your channel I
think a better word for actually
experiencing success on YouTube would be
commitment there's something about
shifting your mindset to say I'm going
to commit to uploading consistently I'm
going to commit to learning new skills
I'm going to commit to improving my
content and the quote we're looking out
today is in the midst of chaos there is
also opportunity I think the reason that
a lot of people don't start is they're
just afraid that maybe the ship is
sailed the window of opportunity is
closed and nothing could be further from
the truth it might feel that there's a
lot of chaos on YouTube a lot of
competition a lot of frustration maybe
you've been uploading for a while and
you're kind of discouraged by the
results that you're getting but friend
there is still massive opportunity maybe
you've been in a season of setbacks
where you actually have had health
challenges or family challenges or
financial challenges coming against you
but I love this quote from Napoleon Hill
and it says this every adversity every
failure every heartache carries with it
the seed of an equal or greater benefit
what every small YouTuber needs to know
is that the opportunity is massive on
YouTube right now but the only way you
can unlock that opportunity is by taking
massive action and not just by starting
but committing to consistency Francis
Bacon says a wise man will make more
opportunities than he finds what does
that mean he will create opportunities
I've heard that the definition of luck
is when hard work and preparation meet
so what does that mean it means I'm
making opportunities it means I'm
uploading videos it means that the more
up videos I upload the more chances I
have to have a breakout video experience
some growth hit a thousand subscribers
get my channel monetized opportunity is
all around us waiting for the wise and
the observant eye to discover it but it
means starting it means taking action
one of the reasons small UT tube
channels fail is they fail to start and
they fail to stick with it number two
the reason that's small and new YouTube
channels fail is they don't embrace the
law of sacrifice here's the quote from
The Art of War who wishes to fight must
first count the cost I think that a lot
of small YouTube creators underestimate
the amount of energy and time and
emotions and willpower it takes to
really start a YouTube channel and one
of the reasons we can know for sure that
the majority of people
underestimate the level of sacrifice
needed to succeed on YouTube is because
critics say oh YouTubers why don't you
get a real job that very common
statement reveals that a lot of people
have no clue the amount of grit and work
and mental energy and mental toughness
and time it takes to start a successful
YouTube channel the strategy the
planning the learning the skill building
and so one of the big reasons that new
and small all YouTube channels fail is
they don't embrace the law of sacrifice
what's the law of sacrifice in order to
go up you've got to give up I think that
sometimes we think that we can kind of
just dabble on the side with the channel
and we'll just get lucky and it'll just
blow up and we'll just go viral and then
we hear one or two stories of that
happening and we think that maybe
that'll happen to us the truth is that's
not that common what's more common is
people consistently uploading over weeks
months oftentimes years continuing to
learn continuing to figure out branding
and online marketing and online business
and really honing in their strategy and
there's a lot of times a Tipping Point
study any of the great video podcasts or
podcasts or YouTube channels and
oftentimes they'll say yeah it was year
three it was year four it was year seven
when momentum really started to pick up
and it wasn't year seven of giving like
a half-hearted effort for the first six
years it was actually seizing the
opportunity it was starting and actually
being committed to consistency over a
period of time that led to the
Breakthrough what are you willing to
sacrifice for the success of your
YouTube channel I'm not saying you
should sacrifice the things that matter
most in life of course you have
priorities like your health and your
family and your kids or whatever your
dependents or responsibility is but can
you sacrifice some entertainment can you
sacrifice some Leisure are you willing
to sacrifice some wasted time are you
willing to sacrifice scrolling on social
media I'm not talking about building
your business I'm just talking about
scrolling randomly instead of studying
or recording your next most important
video I think that a lot of small
channels want to get disproportionate
success results without putting in the
necessary amount of work said
differently than necessary amount of
sacrifice are you ready to start or grow
your YouTube channel do you feel stuck
and need help connecting the dots join
this free web class where you'll learn
the step-by-step playbook for YouTube
success we've helped thousands of
purpose-driven entrepreneurs just like
you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at
thinkmasterclass.com number three they
give up too soon this is one of my
favorite quotes from The Art of War and
it's this opportunities multiply as they
are seized I want to encourage you if
your YouTube channel is small right now
if your business is small right now I've
been there and a lot of other people
have been there as well everybody starts
at zero and there's no doubt about it
that I actually think you're in the
hardest season of the whole thing I'm
facing a lot of challenges today it is
difficult to run a small business with
the financial challenges and the team
challenges that we have but there's no
doubt about it I was working at a whole
different level of sacrifice and stress
and a lot loneliness and pressure in the
early days of building my YouTube
channel and building my business it
takes a lot of grit and it takes a lot
of time to build momentum why does this
quote opportunities multiply as they are
C's apply to people giving up too soon
because you have to invest so much
energy to get the channel going get the
growth going get the momentum going get
even your knowledge going get get the
skill set get the understandings get the
unlocks and as you stick with it though
you more opportunities will lead to more
opportunities if you were starting let's
say a video podcast or an interview show
early on it's like impossible to get
guests because you have no influence but
eventually once you have some guests
then others will say yes and maybe
c-listers will start saying less and
then B listers will and then eventually
a-listers might be coming on your
podcast why because opportunities
multiply as they are seized but the only
way to create create that rhythm of
momentum of breakout videos of brand
deals emailing you of connections and
your network growing is by investing the
time necessary to get the momentum going
in a book by John Maxwell called the 21
irrefutable laws of leadership and as
always in the show notes we'll link to
the Art of War it's a great book for
YouTube creators and anybody that's
interested in strategy to read 21
irrefutable laws of leadership is an
essential too it's one of my favorite
books and one of the laws of leadership
is the law of the Big Mo every content
creator needs to know this what is the
Big Mo it's momentum momentum begets
momentum and the best way to start is to
start because once you start getting
momentum eventually there's some wind in
your sails eventually you've got some
stuff happening you don't have to get it
started every time you're living off of
the momentum it is through small
hard-fought victories that lead to
bigger battles and bigger wins so when
you're at the start the key is don't
give up too soon to illustrate an
example of this I think about the power
of building your network of contacts of
relationships of people you know of
people you've added value to of people
you're following and people that are
following you on social media and I
think about this year I'm about to speak
at VidCon I'm going to be on a panel and
as I'm going into this event we're also
going to be shooting some video podcasts
and one of the things that was
interesting as I was thinking about this
year was all of the different people I
know and people I can text or people I
can DM or people who know me as I
approach this VidCon now you might be
saying Sean that's easy for you to say
your think media think media podcast now
yeah but it hasn't always been this way
this is now like over a decade think
media itself the channels over 10 years
old and now there's so much momentum
that opportunities continue to multiply
and you might be thinking well good for
you I'm just starting but remember I had
to just start and I remember my first
VidCon I felt very insecure I didn't
know anybody there it felt like
everybody else was more established
because they were that everybody else
had bigger YouTube channels because they
did but everybody else knew more than me
and understood the industry and
understood the business more because
they did but now I've actually either
been attending or speaking at this event
for coming up on a decade and
opportunities are multiplying and I
continue to seize those opportunities
it's a little bit easier now because
I've got the Big Mo on my side I've got
momentum it's still challenging but I
want you to hear my heart in those early
days I get it you're fighting hard
battles I get it you are facing some big
challenges and it's super lonely there's
no one else necessarily around you
encouraging you you're the leader that
has to create the momentum you're the
person that has to motivate yourself get
up out of bed get on camera go to the
event register for the class invest in
the course and buy the book study skill
up practice sacrifice because most small
channels they honestly just give up too
soon there is a time to Pivot there is a
time to perhaps shut one YouTube channel
down and then start a different one more
intelligently I have three Failed
YouTube channels that were actually
educational lessons that helped me
eventually launch a successful one I
didn't give up on the dream but I did
change the approach the niche or the
strategy or the tactics and so
ultimately I want to encourage you don't
give up too soon momentum takes time to
build and opportunities multiply as they
are seized and so number one is start
commit and seize the opportunity number
two embrace the law of sacrifice and
number three don't give up too soon but
you may be wondering Sean why what are
some actual tactical YouTube strategies
I can use to get views and we gotta land
the plane on the podcast today but if
you are hungry for the main strategy
that we are using right now at think
media that's generating around 350 000
views every single day right now whether
we upload new videos or not we do have a
free on-demand class that will teach you
that strategy step by step if you just
type in the URL
thinkmasterclass.com you can watch it
for free or there's a link in the show
notes as well where you can get access
to that and again as soon as this
podcast is over you can just go watch it
enter your name email and I'll send you
a link to watch the free training where
basically you can look over my shoulder
and I will break everything down for you
step by step I want to thank you for
being a part of the think media podcast
community and if you've been loving this
series where we're really talking about
different strategies that we're learning
from military strategists of old that
have surprising potency for today's
challenges on YouTube we'll link to that
entire Series in the show notes and make
sure to subscribe because future
episodes are coming soon if you got
value today can you like rate and review
the podcast wherever you watch or listen
I appreciate you so much sending you
love and respect and I can't wait to
connect with you in a future episode